we've celebrated her birthday in sixteen
Candles with her and we've gone to the
prom with her and pretty and pink
tonight she's going to present the Oscar
for a special visual effects Molly
Ringwald
have you ever seen glowing aliens
lurking among us or a stone that talks
or a suit of armor that was alive well
before you say no watch this Ken Ralston
Ralph McQuarrie Scott Farrar and David
berry for cocoon Dennis Muren KITT West
John Ellis and David Allen for young
Sherlock Holmes
well venting in windrow Jean Harris and
Michael Lloyd for return to us and the
winner is the winners are Ken Ralston
Dizzy's wait I'm little nervous I would
like to thank the Academy
everyone is Industrial Light and Magic
who worked so hard on this show
including Bill Kimberlin Laurie Vermont
ray Gilbert E the entire animation
department my wife Robin I'd also like
to thank greg cannom who did the makeups
James Horner who did the great film
score that made our work look twice as
good as it was Richard zanuck David
Brown Lili fini zanuck and of course the
man that I think in the future the very
near future that will be up here as a
recipient Ron Howard thank you thank
dick and Lily for having me on the show
and to the guys at ILM that really took
an interest in the sketches that I made
thank you this is a great picture to be
involved with
I want to thank Robert Hall Robert Hill
Steve dolly the entire company at ILM my
wife Mary Katherine and Maggie and
especially George Lucas who started ILM
in the first place
thank you
but really like to thank the Academy and
the producers of the film cocoon for
this really special honor I'd like to
thank ILM I'd really like to thank ILM
general manager Warren Franklin who has
gotten mentioned yet and I'd like to
thank Eddie Jones Ken Smith Ralph Gordon
and Tom Rossiter and the members of the
ILM optical department I'd like to thank
my wife Wendy my mom and my dad like I'd
like to say hello to my two boys star
Rudy come with me
thank